let's talk about Donald Trump's America
Donald Trump's America is one where
being president is really really good
for your personal businesses and indeed
the Embassy of kuwait has now allegedly
cancel the contract that they had with
the Washington DC four seasons just days
after the presidential election and they
have relocated the eighth the event to
where none other than to Trump
International Hotel in Washington DC why
did they do this they say that there was
political pressure to hold their
national day celebration at the
president elects hotel the Kuwaiti
embassy has regularly held this event at
the four seasons in the georgetown
neighborhood of washington DC and a
source says that they abruptly canceled
the reservation after members of the
Trump Organization pressured the
Ambassador to instead move the event to
a hotel owned by Donald Trump think
progress was also able to review
evidence confirming the sources account
and indeed kuwait has now signed a
contract with Trump International Hotel
that by the way is that hotel I told you
that shortly after the november eighth
election Donald Trump had like a hundred
or so diplomats from different countries
at that hotel and some of them came out
of that Pat saying oh well yeah when we
come to DC will stay at this hotel
because we want to look good for the
president-elect that's exactly what's
going on here this is a payment to the
president-elect yeah this is the story
that keeps coming back and it's clear
that when january twentieth rolls around
if he doesn't divest from these assets
that have a clear conflict of interest
yet he's gonna be in violation of the
Constitution and the emoluments clause
what on earth would it do in terms of uh
stopping the conflicts of interest for
Donald Trump to turn over this hotel to
one of his kids or to somebody else he
knows about the hotel and he knows that
his family and friends and work and and
and employees stand to benefit from
people going to this hotel that the
Donald Trump doesn't understand the
first thing about what a blind trust is
and the first secretary of the embassy
of Kuwait said that he couldn't confirm
or deny that they are indeed
the Trump Hotel nobody from the Trump
Organization has commented but as I
mentioned think progress is reviewed the
documents this is exactly what we
predicted after that meeting Trump had
the diplomats to show them around his DC
hotel this is to gain favor with Donald
Trump why hold an event at the
competition will do with it Trump's
hotel and it's also not just Kuwait
because political reported that Bahrain
also decided to host their national day
reception at none other than Donald
Trump's Washington DC hotel they made
the decision on December 7th that is
under two weeks after Donald Trump's
little show off my hotel two diplomats
event in DC the kleptocracy could not be
any easier and more cushy for Donald
Trump and remember it's only corruption
and paid a play when it's about Hillary
Clinton's emails and the Clinton
Foundation what are the values that are
being promoted by this type of oligarchy
it's always good to think about how the
trumpets would defend this if you were
to go to trump supporters and say with
this Trump's got this hotel going to be
the president he has diplomats come over
and check out the hotel and then you've
got Kuwait and Bahrain and and clearly
other countries are thinking about this
because they said so after that meeting
at Trump's hotel effectively sending
money to the president I think that they
would have two defenses Pat one is hey
he won the business hotel business is a
free market and those countries decided
completely in the open and free market
that the best deal for them was to stay
at Donald Trump's hotel and then the
other way that they would defend it
would be my guest at is they'd say
that's not Donald Trump the president
that's Donald Trump's organization those
are two completely different and
unrelated entities yeah I think a lot of
these foreign dignitaries aren't going
to realize that this is a drain direct
conflict with our Constitution that's
funny to this hotel is maybe 10 15
minutes away from the White House and
symbolically right on Pennsylvania
Avenue between the White House in the
Capitol the letter of this and the
spirit of it based on the short drive
from the White House to the
hotel both are very very clear conflicts
of interest blind trust right Donald you
should figure out what that means before
you're quick to say that that's exactly
what you're doing gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s